[Music]
in extreme parenting news submitted
because I'm Batman
oh wait coffee uh I'm Batman a father
has sparked controversy after subjecting
a group of kids up to exercising in
sub-zero temperatures did you hear about
a cloak off so uh there's this guy he's
like a Russian weightlifter herself a
medalist at the Olympics and he was just
talking about he was saying he thinks a
lot of Russian athletes are just tougher
because it's pretty normal for their
dads to have the kids jump in like
sub-zero waters just toughen them up
like that's kids and it's like a it's
like a nationwide thing so everyone is
groomed to kind of deal with pain and
kind of like these internal battles
we've been here they talk about like
people from Ohio being a lot tougher
than people from San Diego
cuz it's cold yeah but what how come
we're still really good in the Olympics
then if we we're pretty good it's not
genetic variety we're not as good but
we're still pretty good no it's because
it's because of our genetic variety so
we have all kinds of so we just pull
talents from the best of the best of the
races like we get we have Chinese people
to kill and we have Chinese Americans to
do badminton we have these people to do
this like the more these badminton super
cool to tell with you we're real in mmm
like really hot for like one week or
something because never a really good
season to that yeah okay that makes
sense yeah I'm gonna play you guys a
clip they're just so talented that they
don't need to have that much willpower
do we have a country and we have a lot
of resources to do in the country oh you
guys we have a lot of luxury so that we
can focus on sports where our other
nations are worried about food yeah
where our kid can go outside and play
basketball because he doesn't do and
there's this basketball camp and
Technology
so your Russian friends are they like
not eating caviar like what's going on I
don't know because I haven't spoken with
them that much the other thing opposite
that Russia and China in some places
have have kind of a recruiting system
when they're young and out full such
where kids are going in they're learning
they're now selling them yeah they
learned gymnastics at some basic
state-sponsored sport and then when
they're 10 years old you're like ah this
kids probably gonna be six foot he's
gonna go to the volleyball camp this
kids really fast but short he's gonna go
to soccer camp this kid's short and
plump he's gonna go to powerlifting so
they're athletic s-- are different
because it's like the government
sponsoring all of this stuff and then
making it move whereas us it's all
privatized for sure and we're trying to
get into like basketball or yeah I think
I think it's that diversity that bar
talked about and then the luxury where
our kids get to do whatever the heck
they want like obviously some kids have
it better than others but majority of
people don't have to worry about cutting
wheat to make bread yeah yeah so this
dude they call him Eagle dad the sixth
place in China by the way so though
Eagles sounds are let's tiger mom and
Eagle dad yeah dad Eagle dad and Tiger
mom yeah so this guy's video back in
2012 and went viral of his ten year old
son he was jogging in minus 13 degrees
Celsius Wow holy [ __ ] isn't that like
negative 50 Fahrenheit that's work now
that's [ __ ] crazy
55 degrees negative negative 85 right
where the hell is it negative 55 8 8
degrees Fahrenheit high pick a bundle up
he'll be alright
oh that's Boston that's the Midwest yeah
I've been in it I've been in it
Timmy oh there last week it was [ __ ]
1 degree when I was there dude sad sad
2012
looks like a good time cuz he's like
always doing this like his dad always
makes them like train in the snow
cryotherapy is a thing people pay for
this [ __ ] yeah but this one viral effect
and then so now I'm gonna show you guys
a clip of what that's what's going
around is he like on Jack now and like
[ __ ] killing it was he sobbing while
resuming he was laughing it seemed like
you liked that picture at least yeah
you're like smiling it is shocking
though for sure yeah what about you have
a time to ever time how long he's gonna
be up there I'm not sure actually I
think it's only shocking cuz I'm a weak
piece of [ __ ] now we're not used to it
and and yeah I wasn't right different my
my parents would show me karate camp in
Japan and they'll be like in the snow
and our sensei went did that when he was
young too but they basically throw you
in there they throw you in frozen creeks
and then you have to do your punches and
everything as a six year old seven year
old and they would be like yeah so we're
watching this documentary like this
we're gonna send you to karate camp and
then I'm like hell yeah they were trying
to scare me but I was like yeah I don't
know how bad it's gonna be I just think
like oh look at these cool kids even now
it sounds fun you watch like the
Patriots game like oh they're playing in
the snow that looks at the best price so
cuz I'm probably gonna cry when I'm
there like why do you I don't want to do
this no more dad you know yeah so
earlier I mentioned that he was 10 years
old he's 10 years old now but when this
went viral he was four years old
oh yeah so then now there's dad the
eagle dad uh he had this like camp where
he's treating you like that I don't know
that feed them just 13 kids yes enough
that his own oh now he's taking thirteen
children ten boys three girls I started
on Academy pretty much oh wow what sport
just be tough Spartan Race I'm gonna
play a video clip so you guys can see is
he military just dressed that way this
is a duck hunters into it you know whoa
when I went to China there were a lot of
non military guys wearing military thing
cards or whatever they had like pea
coats and a [ __ ] like Russian looking
hat with a star something like they just
say just trying to hide from the scene
that's all the parts blend into this if
I say that about us camels I don't know
Oh truth you go ahead to tell you go
yeah that's different yeah they look
like it's like it's military school or
something like that that's kind of cool
though matching jackets this is how you
make beef and broccoli okay for six
months before the big hoedown
wim hof you know him
for smiling like a motor
you may even teach them how to punch
right there like a skateboard tire this
morning I was really tight on the bed
you look like a roller over there this
reminded me attacked me they feel like
it's torture that this is child abuse
and all that stuff and are these people
from the US or from China that are
outraged China oh is that the trainer
this is the dad he looks like he needs
to do the amazing like you see a Navy
SEAL nails a haircut like this you're
Amelia not scared anymore
he needs better branding yeah so we
don't know the purpose of our shirt on
yeah there's that dude I think his
name's wim hof don't quote me here we're
going places a lot of [ __ ] say man yeah
wim HOF I don't know if these are two
things one there's a guy that can run in
the snow I think he almost ran like a
marathon in the snow barefoot
they called him a mutant he had zero
damage Wow second like swimming i
schooled wim HOF stuff there's a type of
breathing that when you go through this
training you can learn how to you can
create your own temperature either way
up down oh yeah so wim HOF that's the
creator of that so I think wim Hof's one
of the most popular I don't know if he's
the creator and I also don't know if wim
HOF is the runner or not but if you get
your heart rate blood temperature oh
thank you
breathing techniques yeah or you get
yourself ready like revved up to throw
your hardest punch or revved up to do
your best sprint so performance style
too and then
marathon guy came out with no like ice
damage I can't think of it right now
frostbite but it's nothing nice day same
thing at 30 percent of a lot of stuff
yeah yeah he did get hurt so then these
kids are gonna be warriors yeah what's
what what what I what I was picturing
now is like when I was a kid like you
know yep putting like really hard
circumstances but then later on when
you're all done you get to tell these
stories that's when it's really cool
when these kids are like I remember when
I was like five at like and then I was
going through like the snow and I was
getting like ice water poured on me like
those are the cool stories I think the
later on true you know forth uh yeah
I've heard like stories with like
grandparents of Nick you know back to my
day I would have to hike in the snow for
ten miles to get to school or whatever
but then that like with the people that
they're telling these stories to they're
always like yeah whatever grandpa I
don't know if they're really gonna be
that cool and you're giving them a
chance now because now there's videos be
like yeah [ __ ] I [ __ ] told you I did
this you little [ __ ] yeah depends
because like you know life our
grandparents grew up during the Great
Depression and it's like they had to be
tough to survive in that climate and now
it's like we got things easy for us so
it's almost like you know you don't need
to you don't need to do it that hard and
it may be people that are complaining
and whatever they're from you know
Shanghai or whatever like a nice city
they're rich they don't they can't
imagine their own children going through
this but what if for these guys they're
like middle-class to like maybe even
peasant and they're like man we got to
find a way to toughen up our kids so
they can work harder or something he's
saying like Oh dad he said quote
children must exercise the will of the
whip their will so that they become a
hard-working spirit they will remember
this scene from today for the rest of
their life I think my only hiccup is
that I need more of a point to do it
what like being tough is cool but
there's other ways to be tough then you
can teach lessons it's for willpower
yeah I guess but like like if think
those wanna be athletes or if they have
if they have a funnel to go somewhere
cuz like just torture doesn't make you
tough
observing - in my opinion absorbing
torture doesn't make you tough like what
are these kids gonna do they're they're
not really we're gonna run away from dad
in the snow naked like they have no
other option but if they're gonna be
like a soldier or if they're gonna be a
snowboarder a box letter maybe yeah
maybe then there's a purpose for it
maybe like the purpose is discipline
like I guess but I don't know I I think
cuz we don't know the whole story if
he's not teaching lessons while he's
dumping ice or something and then you're
not teaching him anything you're just
putting them through torture if there's
no lesson behind it yeah like joe said
if maybe if he's teaching them hey we
need to absorb this pain and be able to
work for six hours or or whatever then
sure to better your life but if there's
no lesson along with it then it's just
torture maybe it's one of those like
well it's mind over but like if you can
get through this you can get through
anything you know at the end of you
didn't think you would get hurt I guess
there's a lecture or at least some
teachers I'm not saying [ __ ] it's just
that's what I'm worried though like if
you just like this will make you better
Wow and it won't make him better kind of
time I like the karate kid theme or like
he's painting the fence there's no why
yes technically that's torture until the
end he finds out he's not learning in
here that's true but Chinese people
let's make up poppers and [ __ ] so I'm
sure he's making some [ __ ] the cool
property in like martial arts and
Buddhism and stuff there are meditation
techniques where like you're training
and trying to meditate under a cold
waterfall or something like that because
you don't want your physical body to
interfere with whatever thoughts you
have yeah and if he did something like
that like you know whatever's happened
to you happening to you physically you
still want to have that strong mentality
it makes sense yeah I'm in right I'm in
for that but I'm not in for just ripping
a four-year-old out in the snow and be
like this is what you get yeah no party
time
daddy's broken you'll learn it now
dumping ice on his ass
yeah it's it's hard to say if this is
right or wrong or whatever
it goes back to culture are the parents
signing the kids up for it it feels like
they are but I was trying to find that
out to like you know I'm pretty sure
he's not pulling random kids off the
street and then their parents show up
like why I guess it's a good
yeah the only thing I would hope for is
like met like adequate medical like a
tent like if it's there and then if he
knows the limits like you know like most
of these things like a Spartan Race or
whatever there's just staff ready to go
and whatever yeah I mean they do mention
that he was he was training these kids
for six months to be able to go through
this like I guess this is like the final
test okay yeah so maybe there's a
progression yeah I might be into it
you